fantastic now the pre draw cash function
has some tricky math that will go ahead
and walk through here the first thing
we'll need to do is determine the number
of canvases that we're going to use
along the X and Y axis to do this we
actually divide the entire pixel size by
the canvas tile size and then floor the
value note that we add the one here to
round up ensuring that any pixels that
fall outside of this division operation
are actually covered and added to our
canvas from there we do a simple
two-dimensional for loop that walks
through and creates a new canvas tile
and set the x and y values equal to the
position of X offset x tile size once
that's done we simply concatenate this
new canvas tile to the already created
array and then we set fully-loaded equal
to true